ADAM CARPENTER: So
as Sarah just said,
my name is Adam Carpenter, and
I head the Developer Business
Growth team at Google Play.
As mobile developers, one of
the most powerful resources
we have available
to us is our data.
With data, we can understand
what's happening right now,
and we can also look
back and try to identify
why that's occurred.
Our data lets us identify
problems in the game,
find solutions, and ultimately
grow our businesses.
Now, in terms of
this presentation,
I'm going to talk through
some patterns, some trends,
and some insights
that we've been
able to identify with the
data at Google Play in each
of these three areas.
Additionally, I'm going to
share a number of key benchmarks
across them that you can
take back to your teams,
compare to the data from
your own data warehouse,
and identify whether there
are problems in your games
that you can maybe
try and solve.
Now, to start off,
the first thing I'm
going to focus on retention.
And for me, when you think
about installs retention,
three of those key KPIs
for installs performance
is the retention number
itself, the buyer conversion
from your install cohorts,
and the average revenue
per install.
But in my mind, retention is the
most fundamental metric for us.
Because if you can't
retain your players,
you can't make any money.
If you can retain them,
you can always figure out
how to make money off of them.
And one other note I want to
make for this presentation--
for the purposes of the
numbers in this section,
I'm going to call
day 1 retention
as the day of the user's
first session start
and day 2 as the next day.
I know a great many of you tend
to use retention as base zero.
So if you're used to
thinking that nomenclature,
just subtract one
from each date.
To give you some benchmarks
and an understanding of what
retention looks like-- day 2
retention looks like across
the top couple hundred
apps on Play, 38%--
that's the median value.
And that's a good target to
shoot for and think about it.
But if you really want to strive
for excellence, if you really
want to be in the top decile,
shoot for a day 2 retention
of about 52%.
Another way to think
of this, though,
is that our day
2 retention tends
to range between 22% and 52%.
But if we flip it around, it
actually means that 48% to 78%
of the users who
install and play
our games for the
very first time today
won't be back tomorrow.
They just won't come back.
It's really kind of
a staggering number
when you think about
how much time and effort
we devote to creating
our games, how much money
was spent on acquisition.
And one of those
questions that I
had when I was working
on the developer side
is how can I improve
my retention?
Is it good enough?
What I'm hoping to
do here is show you
some signals that occur
in the very first day that
can help you understand
whether your retention is good,
and if it's not,
maybe some things
to check for to
potentially improve it.
So when I was on
the developer side,
and we were looking at installs
performance and the retention
on the first day, generally
speaking, what we would look at
is the level that users
got to or the tutorial
checkpoint that they reached.
However, those tend to
be game-specific metrics,
and they're not really useful
for comparing across games.
Because people level at
wildly different rates
depending on what the game is.
Tutorial checkpoints all vary.
But a metric that we've
been able to develop
at Google Play,
which is much more
of an apples-to-apples
comparison,
looks at the amount of time that
users spend on their first day
and compares it to the
day 2 retention rates.
So to give you an idea
of what this looks like,
broadly across the ecosystem--
and this is for the top 200 IAP
games--
you end up with a curve
that looks like this.
It starts off at,
let's say, maybe
18-ish percent and
steadily trends
upwards with each
successive minute played.
And of course, this makes sense.
There's a reasonable
assumption that the more people
play on the first day, the
more likely they are to return,
since the more they
play, the more likely
they are to be having fun.
Where this data gets
a bit interesting
is when we actually take those
top couple of hundred games
and break them out
into quartiles.
And so what we're
looking at here
is the top couple of
hundred games broken out
based on their day 2 retention.
What we can actually
see is that,
by and large, each
of these quartiles
exhibits largely
the same pattern
after the first 10 minutes.
They all curve upwards
and to the right
with a
steadily-decreasing slope.
But it's in the first 10 minutes
where the most interesting
stuff starts to emerge.
Zooming into that,
we can see here
that there's very different
shapes and experiences
and patterns that emerge just
within that first 10-minute
window.
The top quartile--
the green line here--
they start out strong and
just steadily increase.
But the blue line, the
second quartile down, you
actually see this
short, 90-second window
where retention is largely
flat, and only then
does it begin to pick up.
And that pattern actually
increases once you get down
to the third quartile.
This particular line
here looking at the--
yeah, a quarter of
those top games--
that shows retention is largely
flat for the fourth minute.
But in a number of
games I've looked at,
you can actually see that
flat period extend out
all the way to 10 minutes.
And then once we get into the
bottom quartile, the worst
performers, you can actually
see retention decline
across the first few minutes
and only then begin to rise.
So to give you some
context and understand just
how impactful this first
five or 10 minutes is,
what I want to look
at is the performance
of the top quartile, the green
line, the best performers,
versus the fourth quartile,
the red line here.
And what this graph
shows is the amount
of time played on the
first day on the x-axis
and the cumulative percent of
lost players on the y-axis.
So looking at that
fourth quartile,
they actually lose 46%
of their new installs
by the fifth minute, and they
lose 58% of their installs
by minute 10.
Basically, that
fourth quartile--
and these are all really
strongly-performing games--
half of their players don't even
last 10 minutes in the game.
In contrast, the top
quartile, the best performers,
they see only 17% of their
users lost at minute five
and only 24% of their
users lost at minute 10.
Now, think of this from your own
game and your own perspective.
What could you do if you
were in the bottom quartile
to move your retention
up and effectively
be able to retain over
twice as many users on day 2
and all of the following
retention days?
How much would
that help your DAU,
and how much would that
improve your revenue?
Two of the
anti-patterns that we've
been able to identify
in Google Play's data
are what I've started
dubbing "the flats."
What we see here is
largely flat retention
that persists for the first five
to 10 minutes, and only then
does it begin to rise.
And the other one
that we've identified,
I'm calling it "the gorge."
Here is where we
actually see retention
falling for the first
couple of minutes
and only then beginning to rise.
So these are two patterns
that are worth checking
for in your own game data.
Get your data teams, get
your data scientists,
get your business analysts
to actually pull this and see
what your game is looking like.
And if you do find that this
is occurring in your game,
here's some things
to think about.
Because all of these
have adverse impact
on that first five to
10-minute experience.
Large secondary
downloads, especially
if users are on a
strong Wi-Fi connection,
are going to cause them to
bounce out of your game.
Likewise, if your
tutorials aren't fun,
if they aren't representative
of what the game really is,
that can alienate players.
And additionally,
slow loading times
are important to consider,
because your new users are not
yet invested in their game.
So if they experience a lot
of slow loading screens,
they're more likely to
quit out and go to a game
that loads in near real time.
And finally, I would say think
about your lobby experience.
If a user coming
out of the tutorial
doesn't know how to get
back into the action,
how to start building their
base, or how to have fun,
they're probably
going to get confused,
and they're probably
going to leave.
Moving on to engagement, if
you think about what most of us
want-- and I
certainly wanted this
when I was working on
the developer side--
is we always want more users.
Since the more uses we have
gives us greater ability
to monetize during our supply
side sales and our demand side
events, it also allows us, if
we're showing ads in the game,
to show ads to a significantly
great number of users.
And in addition to
increasing our DAU,
we also want to maximize
our DAU/MAU ratio,
since the higher that is, it
means that fewer users are
churning out of the game
and that they're coming back
every single day.
In an ideal world, our DAU
would be equal to our MAU,
meaning that nobody would
ever churn out of the game.
They'd come back
every single day.
But we know that
this isn't the case.
Veteran players churn
out of the game.
New installs churn out
because of poor retention.
Even our frequent users don't
come back each and every day
due to a lack of strong
return mechanics.
And so there's two
common stickiness metrics
that a lot of
developers look at.
And these are the DAU/WAU
ratio and the DAU/MAU ratio.
And to give you some
ideas about what
you should shoot for,
55% for a DAU/WAU ratio
puts you right at the median,
so that's a good starting place.
And 31% for that DAU/MAU ratio
is, again, a good starting
place to shoot for.
But ideally, you want to
be much better than that.
And something to consider
when you're looking at it
and trying to
improve these ratios
is actually the relationship
between the two of them.
This is a plot that I had never
done on the developer side
because I didn't really
have enough data points.
But in leveraging
the Google Play data,
I was able to create this.
And what it does is it has the
DAU/WAU ratio on the x-axis
and the DAU/MAU
ratio on the y-axis.
And what we can actually
see is this very strong
linear relationship
between the two.
And what this helps
us to understand
is that if we want to increase
our monthly active users
and our monthly
uniques, we can actually
start not by testing
changes that function over
an entire month, but
test changes that
work in seven-day intervals.
And one of the big
advantages to this
is we don't have to wait
28 to 30 days before we
start getting results back.
We can actually see results
coming back in seven days.
And effectively, within
any given window of time,
we can run four times
as many test tests
if we're focusing on weekly
versus focusing on monthly.
But one of the other interesting
things that we can do
is we can actually
pull it all the way in.
This is a metric I started
to work with at Google Play.
It's not something I'd ever
use on the developer side.
And what it does is it looks
at the percent of today's DAU
who come back tomorrow.
And it's just trying
to understand,
as a loose proxy for churn,
how engaged are our users.
Now, if we take that
plot from before
and instead put this
DAU return percent
on the x-axis and
the DAU/WAU ratio
on the y-axis, what we
actually see is that,
again, it's positive and linear.
And what this tells
us is that if we
want to increase our
stickiness factors,
the most important
thing for us to do
is start focusing
at the daily rate.
It's hugely important.
And it's advantageous
because, if you
think about it,
weekly versus monthly,
you can run four
times as many tests.
Daily versus monthly,
you can run--
depending on how
you do your month--
28 or 30 times as many tests.
And so fundamentally,
the most important thing
you can do to boost your
active users in your engagement
is focus on tomorrow.
Focus on what is actually
going to bring your users back
and keep them engaged.
Now, it's important to
understand and think
about how do you know if you're
doing well enough, especially
this new metric that most of you
probably haven't experienced.
And so here's some
target ratios looking
across the entire top
couple hundred apps,
couple hundred IAP apps, that
you can take back and compare.
And that 77% number--
that's an important
one to shoot for.
But really shoot for
that high side, 84%.
Try to figure out how do you
get your users to come back
each and every day.
And a few ideas--
a few things that are
worth considering--
are your return mechanics, your
social systems, and your push
notifications, because all
of these have a huge impact.
In case of return mechanics,
let's really celebrate them.
Let's make sure our users
are totally aware of them,
that the return mechanics
are aspirational,
that they're rewarding,
that users are really
strongly incentivized to
come back each and every day
to receive them.
In the case of the social
systems, let's really,
really leverage them.
Because if you think
about it, the games that
have very strong clan systems,
alliances, good chat groups,
substantial friends
benefits-- in those games,
effectively, your players
do the work for you.
If I'm a player
and I have friends
in the game who are relying on
me, it's in my best interest
to be there.
And likewise, if
they're relying on me,
I want to be there for them.
So think about
your social systems
and whether you can
strengthen the existing ones
or add new ones, and let your
players do the work for you.
And finally, on the
push notification side,
think about how you
can personalize them.
How can you create personalized
push notifications targeted
just towards an individual
user or a segment of users
as opposed to, effectively,
spamming all users
at all hours of the day?
Think about trying to
target push notifications
around the normal time
of day that a user plays,
as that's going to be much
more compelling and much more
impactful.
Now, the last thing, I want
to focus on monetization.
And what I'm going
to be talking about
is a metric that I used
really successfully and really
effectively when I was
working on the developer side.
And what will do is
it's going to help
us understand and answer the
question of are our payers
healthy.
Generically speaking,
the industry
has referenced
singular data points,
made claims to the effect of
only 2% of payers actually pay.
However, that's horribly
misleading as a statement,
because generally
speaking, that's
going to be focused more on that
daily buyer conversion number.
It takes into account--
it doesn't take into
account the percentage
of users who are willing to only
open their wallets on a weekly,
monthly, or even
quarterly basis.
And so what you can
do to take a look at,
to understand your
pairs health, is a ratio
that we called PAU/DAU.
And what it is, it's the percent
of your daily active users--
the users who are active today--
that have paid within the
preceding x-day period.
In terms of the time frames
that I used to like to look at,
the ones I found that
were most impactful
were the 7, 30, 90, and
one-year time frames.
And these were
extremely valuable
because they allowed
me to do things
like compare the
users who purchased
within a week versus a month
or the quarter versus a year.
And the other thing that's
really important and really
impactful with
PAU/DAU-- since it's
a measurement of the users who
have already paid in your game,
it helps you to understand
the audience in your game
that's willing to pay.
Because we're always trying
to convert first-time users.
But then once
they've converted, we
need to create incentives
to actually get
them to continue to
open their wallet again
on a regular basis.
So what I'm going
to talk through here
is an example game and show you
some trends and some patterns
in the daily buyer conversion
and how they've impacted
various PAU/DAU ratios.
There's three events that I
want to call out on this chart,
and the first is this
medium-duration event
that occurred, basically,
at the end of January
to the beginning of February,
maybe two, 2 and 1/2,
three-week period.
And what we saw here
is that this event
provided a substantial increase
to the daily buyer conversion.
The other two events are
event B and C. Each of these
occurred for about a day.
They were sales, and they
created a substantial 130%
increase in that daily
buyer conversion.
All three of these are
really, really effective,
but it's interesting
to see what they
did with the PAU/DAU ratios.
So looking at the seven-day
ratio, what we can actually see
is that event A was extremely
effective at monetizing
a very wide number of users.
And effectively, this
event, it actually
caused a lot of non-buyers
or occasional buyers
to pay and open their wallets
during that time versus events
B and C, which got significant
increases to buyer conversion
on that date, but it didn't
do much to incentivize
the occasional buyers to
open their wallets and pay.
So it's something that
you can think about
as you monitor the performance
of the supply side sales
and the demand side
events in your game.
Try to understand
who is actually
paying during those periods.
What are the motivating factors?
What are the incentives?
What is driving those players
to open their wallets?
And you can also-- not
just the seven-day,
but I was mentioning
you have the 30-day
that you can look at.
You have the 90-day
that can look at.
You have the one-year
or even the lifetime.
But just always
try to understand,
when you're running sales
and you're running events,
what incentives are they
creating for players.
Are they aspirational?
Are they desirable?
Are they excellent
value for money?
But what's that motivation?
So in terms of the
PAU/DAU ratios,
I can't give you explicit
values that you could take back.
But what I can give you
is standardized ratios.
The reason is that
PAU/DAU is intimately tied
to your daily buyer conversion.
And some games will have a
daily buyer conversion of 0.5%.
Some games with sophisticated
monetization models,
it might be as much as 3%.
But what you can do is take
your daily buyer conversion,
and if you look at your
seven-day PAU/DAU value,
it should be four times higher.
The 30-day value should
be eight times higher.
The 90 days should be 12 times.
And if you look at that
rolling 365-day window,
it should be about 15 times
higher than your daily buyer
conversion.
Another advantage of PAU/DAU
is the inter-period comparisons
withing your game.
Take a look at--
what this is is it's looking
at the daily buyer conversion--
in this case, a
hypothetical 1.5%,
and the scaling factors
from the previous slide.
What we would see
here is there's
a reasonable expectation
that 6% of this game's DAU
would have paid somewhere
between 31 and 90 days ago.
And an incremental
5% of the DAU would
have paid somewhere between
91 and 365 days ago.
If this was your game, that
would be 11% of your DAU.
So think about it.
How can you actually
incentivize these players?
How can you shift those
effectively quarterly buyers
to being monthly?
Or how can you reactivate
those lapsed buyers?
Now let's say you do start
monitoring a PAU/DAU type
metric, and you are
trying to understand
if there's opportunities,
if there's room for growth.
Here's a few things to consider.
Let's say your game does
run supply-side offers.
Figure out whether you
can better segment them.
Can you put constraints
on the amount
that people can purchase?
Can you segment by
average transaction value,
and in doing so, limit
the amount of assets
that users can get so they
can't stockpile and hoard,
and therefore have to
purchase more frequently?
Also, think about it.
If you see a large
percentage of your users
haven't paid in an
extended amount of time,
create lapsed buyer
offers for them
and almost treat them
like starter packs.
Because the primary
goal if somebody
hasn't paid between
91 and 365 days ago
is to provide them with a
compelling value proposition
to get them to open their
wallet, perceive good value,
and be willing to pay again.
And then for a lot of
the users who are active,
think about whether you
can personalize the events
that you're providing
to them in the game.
And do so in a way that causes
them to drain assets quicker,
and therefore, is
strongly incentivized
to open their wallets and pay.
Now I'm just going
to wrap up real quick
and revisit each
of these sections.
Where we were
looking at retention,
that first five to 10-minute
period is absolutely essential,
and it has such
a critical effect
on your day 2 retention
and all the following days.
So I strongly suggest going
back and generating metrics
like that day 1 minutes
played versus day 2 retention
and see what it looks
like in your game.
And on the engagement
side, think about how
you can focus on tomorrow.
How can you create really
compelling engagement
mechanics, return mechanics,
social systems that
will bring players
back into the game,
make them want to return
each and every day?
And finally, on the
monetization front,
think about your
PAU/DAU ratios and how
they compare to the daily
buyer conversion and use that
to generate insights as to
where users are spending,
how frequently they're
opening their wallet,
and the size of
your player base who
has only paid once in a
quarter or haven't paid in
up to a year.
Thank you very much.